Super city
It's been a few minutes again
today.The 7 secrets of language study.The number one secret is
take the time of a cow.Second name is
the study method that
you like and have fun studying.  Please, the third is
9th, please develop your ability to
pay attention.  Please study. Studying a
language buys time Even if you study a
fake
vocabulary list or rules of distribution,
you will soon forget
it.  The
reason why there is always that is the brain. I
study, but it takes time. Which words do you remember right now?
Which tags are editions and issues?
It's a good color No matter how many examples you see or how much you read the explanations, it's
quite difficult for
you to use it anymore
That's why there are people who request this
.  That
's what's inside. It's a good moment when studying words. It's a positive actor's voice
.
That's why I'm patient as much as possible
How many hours will it take to
process?
I couldn't say it in the way I wanted to say it,
or I forgot a word
.  You should absolutely avoid thinking that no matter how much you study, you won't make much progress.In
my experience, it's gone.
It's a one-
shot, or it's a sentence that I read three months ago
.  I understand  It
's a victory
, and there are times when you say you won, and there are
times when you're not as good as you think.
Well, this is a long-term game,
so it's very important to study the language with patience as the final victory hinges.Thank you
very much.